[Music]
hi there I'm Dana Jacobson from CBS this
morning Saturday today we're bringing
you some of our favorite past of the
dish second helpings if you will
first up meet a superstar Israeli chef
with a fascinating philosophy on life
and a restaurant where people are
dancing on the tables by nights end this
restaurant is based on the same one you
have in tel-aviv yes where did the idea
come from for that first restaurant
there was no idea I have no idea I have
no concepts I ain't concept because
concept is to look for me Bob and to try
to find a system that will succeed it's
a kind of manipulation it is that
philosophy which might help explain the
transformation of al Chinese restaurant
la salon over the course of an evening
when somebody comes in here to dine what
are you hoping they experience or what I
hope a very specific thing that their
life will be changed forever from a meal
for me meal it's not logic to believe in
that but I cannot stop believe in the
early seating has the trappings of a
traditional restaurant but the late
seating morphs into this
a feast for all the senses Shani brought
the Jamboree with him from Tel Aviv but
after years of shaking up the restaurant
scene in his homeland SHINee says he was
looking for new sources of inspiration I
came to New York because I saw and I
understood everybody that is living in
the world is dreaming about that city
it's a huge deep journey started with
Israeli Street food Burley last year he
opened MS nan in New York's Chelsea
Market SHINee says the pita is one of
the best translators of a cities
atmosphere I mean I could take the main
elements of the city and to unselect
them into a food they till the end
entering into a betta when I first came
to New York it had asked myself somebody
one of my suppliers so I'm the student I
have to make a new birth date
Johnnie Sears his brother on one side
with cheese he then folds it which traps
the steam and crisps the cheddar finally
the burger is put inside a pita with
aioli sour cream peppers tomato and
pickles I'm making a fool of myself
eating this because that's how good it
is it's great
my co-hosts are going to hate me because
they don't forget Miz non is also known
for breathing life into a veggie long
thought of as bland the roasted
cauliflower how many flowers do we in
one quality 10 one that is the flower
and that is the leaves around the seed
so in all the Eastham of the gastronomy
[ __ ] used to break when the students one
flower I decided not to break the flower
you should feel this right so it's the
old flower for you
yeah weep you're in snow could break its
it melts in your mouth
Sonny's secret actually believing that
each ingredient is a living creature
with its own will and then developing an
almost metaphysical connection to the
question is tomato is a tomato the
answer will always be no it's not a
tomato it's something else if it's
something is what it is that is the
German what is a tomato what is a
Hammond why they are different what does
the world butter with tomato seeds it's
the best composition in the world
Shanny doesn't just bring his own take
on the food and atmosphere in his
restaurant
you see his philosophy in how they're
run take hostel on which is only open
three nights a week how can that even
work as a business model it's a 1
million dollar question literally right
Johnny says most businesses only make
money a few days a week anyway and after
three nights that go into the wee hours
he and the staff have nothing left to
give
it's almost impossible is to be America
and that America has to be on each dish
to do it every day seven days or six
days and to be real authentic to your
creation it's a big life you cannot do
it you have to refresh your soul before
you are doing it you have to be starved
to do it it almost seems as if al Shani
wants to feed your soul with each bite I
can change your life I can change one
moment
he will experience attrition in this way
of life and in the end people are
climbing the table yeah a little
yeah it's always that good like that
now to open fire cooking but not your
typical backyard barbecue this is eight
hours roasting whole lamb salmon fruits
vegetables and more than a dash of heart
and soul my co-host Jeff Glor has the
story the work began just after 6:00
a.m.
Francis Mullin kept a close eye as two
of his chefs prepped the day's feast
there are so many details it's such a
fragile thing to cook with fires people
think it's a beastly thing it's a manly
thing but it's not it's extremely
fragile first the hanging of the ribeye
slathered in chimichurri sauce each
suspended by wire measured and cut to
precision lengths to control for cooking
time and temperature a technique Mullen
created and is now mastered that was
followed by a dozen organic chickens
both are staples of Mullins custom domes
which are now a global phenomenon next
an array of vegetables and fruits
including pineapples and cabbage wood is
set around the perimeter of the dome and
then lit every day is different
depending on the wind and the heat of
the wood this morning you know it was a
sort of a blind date with this wood
which is great oh I didn't know what
sort of heat we would get from it but it
worked out well the fire has been such
an important thing for us not only for
cooking for shelter for warmth that
whoever sees a fire and sits by a fire
you just just drop it's primal
it's primal
a whole lamb was set on an Iron Cross
nearby then given time lamb is not
something you often see at North
American cookouts and certainly not made
this way okay and now I just flip it
five hours so far five hours so far and
then on this side too I'm going to add a
bit of this delicious moist earnest on
it and that's a mixture of what butter
and herbs I get a sneak preview yeah
hold it from the very edge it's still
warm I always like to pull the first
piece with my hand is it nice it's more
than nice moment also headed inside the
fire with a whole wild salmon you know
look at this beautiful thing look at it
make it sleep here because you want the
fish to be cooked but slightly tied to
the bone still you know so you have to
pull a bit we baste all the food every
hour and so even the pineapples we put
it in this syrup of pineapple every hour
so it's dripping it's wet Francis
Mullins goal at this and every fire omit
needless ingredients which i think is
the most difficult thing in cooking you
know if you have a fish that it's just
cooked in the wood oven and you just put
on it a little sea salt and olive oil I
mean it has to be perfect if you hit
those things it's the most delicious
things you will ever eat almonds
embracing of that bear style has been a
return to his roots in Patagonia I think
that childhood is where we always go
back sometimes you know I'm sitting in a
very difficult meeting and I'm anxious
and I go back to childhood I remember
the rain the snow the wind and I get
cured immediately you remember the fires
I remember the fires yes because we you
know we we lived with fires momen now
makes his fires for celebrity clients
around the world including David Beckham
and Guy Ritchie and Gwyneth Paltrow he's
been a legend in South America for half
his life but his 2000
book seven fires put him on the map in
the United States I think that we
achieved a lot in the books but at the
end you have to start your fire stand in
front of it put your meat and understand
what's happening it's a craft cooking
and you have to do it there's no way out
over and over again over and over again
that's why you know sometimes my chefs a
chef I'm so bored of doing this steak
I've been doing it for two years I can't
stand it anymore and I say well you know
but what you're learning is not about
the steak you're learning about how to
stand how to move and that's something
that you can't learn in a book and
that's the beauty of cooking you have to
do it from that bedded salmon to the
domed meat it's a crossed lamb every
part of the moment presentation is
dramatic well I must say I'm very
honored to be here today
eventually eight hours after the fire
started dinner was served so we're gonna
serve for us the chicken today string
hung chicken with cauliflower and a
criolla sauce salmon somebody else wants
some fish with cabbage and aioli
lamb with sweet potatoes butternut
squash onions and gremolata they give
you one of these guys ribeye with
smashed potatoes and a chimichurri sauce
the fat is very good for dessert burnt
peaches and plums with pineapple
marscapone and amaretto all along with
plenty of wine when people look at your
cooking your life everything what do you
want people to take from the Francis
moment story
I think freedom I think there's a lot of
fear I think the worst enemies we have
our fear and routine because they both
freezes you know they when you're
fearful you're like that and when you're
in routine - you can get out of it and I
think that changes is the most important
thing in life to change the process
up next my co-host Michelle Miller went
to the Yucatan Peninsula to a lush
resort serving humble food while
honoring Mayan culture in the heart of
Mexico on this lush plantation here's
where peaking some beautiful flowers
chef Jorge Vallejo tends to his garden
flower and his harvest
whether grown in the earth or in these
ancient planters it all supplies the
bounty of his new restaurant egg she
which means corn in Mayan it's the story
we want to tell to the people one of the
spinal cords of the Mexican gastronomy
or the Mexican culture it's about corn
so for me is a very I would say
democratic ingredient because it's not
about the monetary value it's all about
the flavor the the pureness of the
ingredient and that's why we want us to
say we are currently his mission to
distinguish a Mayan eating experience by
preparing humble ingredients with modern
Flair and cook it from you know only
from one side like escolar a buttery
fish from the Gulf of Mexico when I gave
it it takes these flavors what are the
main main life I look at you just
digging it up you feel there's no penis
of this of the fish this is really good
it's delicious I hope you enjoyed
equally as delicious the beauty of this
setting it seemed anchors Chablis a
luxury resort built in the grounds of an
old Hacienda his restaurants have become
a retreat for global visitors and
Vallejo says recently have been a bridge
to Mexico's northern neighbor the US I
will say 90% of the people that comes
into the restaurant are not Mexicans
actually we had to give English lessons
to our waiters because probably out of
that 90 percent sixty percent of the
people are American
Akim is 45 minutes from Merida
the Yucatan capital but it feels like a
place from another time this was
actually the factory where they made but
a 19th century plantation that once
produced rope now provides relaxation
for its customers and employment for the
local community so much of this area is
influenced by Mayan culture it is it's
all about my own culture the people
still know these days they are very
proud about their culture they're very
proud about being Mayans they are
actually the ones that keep the
tradition they're the ones that keep the
flavors they're the ones that keep the
keep the environment Mexico is not one
thing if you go to Oaxaca they have
their own traditions they their own
flavors even their own past yeah his own
food story started early with your kid
instead of toys for Christmas you would
ask for a roast chicken
I can eat chicken and rice every day I
have a three-year-old daughter probably
the kids are the most wise people in the
world because they live now the present
for me being a cook or serving people
it's about that that kitchen obsessed
kid who had trouble concentrating in
school decided to give cooking a try I
was just in my own world I was lucky
enough to find something that I can lose
myself which is cooking but Hakeem also
quenches the thirst for another ancient
tradition tequila was born in Mexico
Louis Ronson and Luis Alberto Flores
Muno are experts in tequila you don't
need to pour that much Akim has the
largest tequila collection in the world
3800 bottle strong its oldest the Jose
Cuervo which has been around for 240
years if you want to try a sip
our Mexican dish would not be complete
fire fire without a lesson in the proper
etiquette of tequila sipping because
tequila like the cuisine here in this
pocket of paradise is to be savored oh
wow that's very smooth Tina may be
really high quality spirit that you can
enjoy just a jus enjoy cognac for chef
Alejo the way to honor his Mexican
heritage is to bring that Mayan cuisine
to the world stage and that's what we
want to showcase here in the in the
restaurant the pureness of the
ingredients but how can really works in
a luxury audience mission accomplished
because quintanilla has been rated one
of the top restaurants in the world yes
no I'm filled you know very proud about
what we achieved already and just as I
told you I'm still learning I'm still
like wanted to to do more so for me of
course is Sam as you're saying mission
accomplished but still not finished
this next chef I had the pleasure of
meeting has two hip eateries in
California she's been the subject of a
Netflix documentary and she's a
political adviser to the President of
Mexico inside chef Gabriella cámaras San
Francisco eatery kala fine-dining meets
finger food with her Mexican small place
camara brings a lifetime of cooking
experience into the kitchen but no
formal training the former art history
student doesn't think of her food as art
like painting it just happens to come
out that way
I would start with these take collars
signature trout tostadas with Chipotle
avocado and fried leeks
sort of our little staple this is
fantastic
Kumada garnishes her abalone tostada
with trout roe Oh Robbie bonito flake
infused aioli and the blue flowered herb
borage I don't want to eat it it's too
pretty
hmm I love very simple flavors but I
want them to be bright so that's why I
use a lot of acid in lemon and lime but
it's this dish that blends all her
varied influences so this is pasta but
basta made in a Mexican Spanish way
fried pasta noodles and clams cooked
with liquid tomato and chipotle chili my
mother would say this is not pasta
because what is this deep frying a pasta
delicious yes Kumada is the daughter of
an Italian mother and Mexican father she
was raised in Mexico City what was it
like having those different influences
as a young
it was great and I we always had all
these periods of time that we lived in
Italy or periods in which we came to the
States
or a lot of traveling because of my
parents work and also just because they
really wanted us to have exposure to to
a wider world did you think that food
was your future though I mean I thought
I would always cook and eat well but I
did open a restaurant when I was very
young and I had no idea and I realized
how much I loved it Camero was still in
college in Mexico City when she opened
her first restaurant pulled from our
with three friends it was an experiment
when we were very serious about it we
wanted it to work we invested very
little money we all like scrape from our
savings here and there and it happened
almost immediately contra Mar became a
sensation how do you take what starts as
what sounded like it just started as
let's do this this had to be fun yes and
turn it into the success that it became
I think with a lot of work with a lot of
attention with a lot of caring and I
know that common sense is at least
common sense right but I actually turned
out to be a very good manager just
because I was very my common sense
worked in a restaurant five years ago
Kumada and her family moved to the Bay
Area she was shopping around San
Francisco for a location for a new
restaurant when I found this space and I
thought I need to do something here it's
so good it's it's it's we're sitting in
this is a sink I get it I get it by
sitting here and I saw the beams I
thought of stealing and I saw that it
had that full block a winning and I
really really loved it so that's why I
opened ala along with the main dining
room in the front Kumada operates a taco
stand in the back of the building
taco Scala and last month she and fellow
chef Jessica Koslow opened a new
restaurant
onda in Santa Monica but officially
Kumada has moved back to Mexico City
where she's serving as a cultural
advisor to Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador
mexico's president just happened to be a
customer at contramar
was in San Francisco about two years ago
on business when he stopped by kala to
see her he said
nobody let this time I'm gonna win and
you're gonna have to come back to work
with me in Mexico and I thought first
you win we've gone through this twice
already two elections that have been not
successful Lopez Obrador was elected
president in July 2018
Commodus says the chance to serve all
the people of Mexico was impossible to
turn down I think it's worth my time for
sure and my life to give it a shot at
helping him I never set out to serve
others as a mission but I think that now
it is my mission it's just one more
thing added to Commodus plate this has
muscles right and a little bit of chill
I said I'm not but even with the new
responsibilities she's abiding by the
old saying don't quit your day job and
it's good I think food should be above
ever anything delicious and then success
yeah you can find news and more stories
like this every week on CBS this morning
Saturday and you can find news 24/7
right here on CBS n featuring live
anchored coverage available for free
across all platforms thanks for joining
us take care of each other I'm Dana
Jacobson